Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host on NBC Sports Network and of
course the great website pro football
talk calm Mike where do we stand on this
17 game schedule well I mean the 17 game
schedule is part of the 10-year CBA that
is on the tee for the Union to adopt if
they ultimately adopt it you know one
thing that really hasn't been explained
the way it should be Dan when all this
talk started a few weeks ago of the
NFLPA having meetings with player reps
to talk about the league's proposal the
reality is that through the course of
ten months the NFL and the NFL players
associations negotiating teams reached
an agreement they have an agreement it's
like two lawyers getting together
working out a settlement to a lawsuit
and saying all right now we got to do is
sell it to our clients and the NFLPA has
had a hard time selling it to its
clients in part because the executive
committee which negotiated the deal
voted against accepting to teal on
Friday which is one of those head
scratchers like wait a minute you guys
negotiated the deal and now you're
voting against it and I think where it
all stands very simply is this the NFLPA
is going to go back to the table to try
to get more there's no cost in asking
for more the question becomes how will
the NFL respond to this will they say we
have a deal get out of here
will they say okay fine we'll negotiate
and we'll sweeten the deal and within
that question Dan is the thing that
fascinates me have they already planned
for this and do the owners have a stack
of chips in their pocket that they're
ready to put on the table to get this
done without having to go back and
discuss and vote and wring hands and
gnash teeth over whether or not they're
going to give more they can huff and
puff about the players coming back and
say well this is a real problem we have
to talk about this we have to think
about this and then they ultimately put
on the table what they were going to put
on the table anyway and they get this
done and it feels to me like the NFL
throughout this process is understood
exactly where the ball is going like the
NFLPA is trying to keep track of where
the ball is NFL knows where the ball is
going and I wouldn't be surprised if
they don't already
some extra stuff that they knew all
along they were going to put on the pile
of concessions and offers in terms and
they're gonna do it this week to get the
deal done
yeah I'm right there with you having
covered a couple of these strikes and
lockouts in the last 40 years
unfortunately where it always felt like
there's one or two items that it hinges
on it feels like there's a lot of
ancillary stuff but there's one or two
items I just don't remember the players
having as much of a bargaining chip as
they have with this 17-game well the
problem though is they've spent the last
ten months negotiating based on 17 games
if it's a non-starter
then you tell the NFL at the very
beginning we're not doing 17 games
period ever we're not going to negotiate
on it we're not going to talk about it
because what happens is after you spend
ten months negotiating a deal based on
17 games it's it becomes a given that
you're going to have a deal based on 17
games the question is what do they get
for the 17 games and I think what
happened and when the NFLPA
player representatives Executive
Committee when they started to get
together and start talking about this
after the season ended they were still
feeling the physical effects of a
16-game season which made them more
likely to say we don't want 17 and I
think the farther their bodies get
removed from the end of football season
that cloud is going to start to move
away and they'll be more likely to go
along with 17 but the urgency to get
this done is very real I mean that's you
know what the NFL P it's two deals that
you have to look out for the NFLPA what
they get from the league and what the
league gets from the TV networks and I
think the NFLPA leadership at the very
top the executive director d'amour Smith
has decided everyone gets more if they
do a deal now and they do TV deals
premise on 10 years of labor piece
versus slamming the brakes on everything
and getting maybe less or TV deals now
or lesser TV deals later because of the
specter of a potential work stoppage and
you know your autumn Utley gonna do a
deal based on 17 games when do you do it
and I think demora Smith has made the
judgment right or wrong that everyone
gets a better deal if they get this done
now so then they can maximize the TV
money yeah I just don't understand the
10-year deal I mean it feels like that
this it's gonna be antiquated here like
after five years
well I agree but you know what the more
its premise on a true sharing of the
revenue and they're getting closer and
closer to 5050 48.5 is what the split
will ultimately be now you have to get
your arms around the exemptions and the
exceptions and the stuff they take off
the top and that was a sticking point in
the summertime it's it hasn't been
mentioned much recently but I think you
know the question to be extent to which
the players will help fund new stadiums
that apparently is been resolved you
don't hear anybody complaining about
where things stand on that but as it as
it becomes a true partnership and and
you're sharing the money now the owners
always have the equity and the players
have none which gets overlooked I mean
in the value of the franchise that keeps
skyrocketing but the closer you come to
a 50/50 split of the revenue the more
you can feel like it's a true
partnership and and and I know that
there are some within ownership that
want to approach it that way but there's
also a group of hardliners who their
attitude is screw them lock them out
there they work for us we set the terms
we want 18 games we want this we want
that and and there's kind of a there's
not as you know they're doing a good job
of holding everything together publicly
but I think behind the curtain there is
some difference of opinion among the
owners about how aggressive to be and
they're trying to simulate something
that feels like a real partnership I
don't know if it's a story we're talking
to Mike Florio pro football talk you
have Jim Irsay who had some comments on
Sunday and he said he can't comment on
Andrew Luck potentially coming back am I
making too much of this no I just think
it's wishful thinking by a guy who would
love to solve this quarterback problem
by Andrew Luck coming back now here's
the thing if they go out and spend a
bunch of money on Philip Rivers or
someone else in free agency if he would
come back it would be kind of like Brett
Favre coming back after the Packers had
committed to Aaron Rodgers and they
hadn't even paid Aaron Rodgers at that
point but they were going with Aaron
Rodgers you know if Andrew Luck comes
back now you're just slay the fatted
calf and you welcome them home and you
put him back under center but if they go
out and make a major financial
commitment for a new quarterback and
Luck decides well you know what I feel
pretty good I'm going to come back and
play then the Colts are really in a
tough spot at that point and who knows
what they would do but I would be
surprised if the Colts don't quietly try
to find out whether or not there's any
chance he comes back before they jump
into free
see if they jump into free agency to go
after one of these guys that's out there
and I usually take the opposite approach
of whenever I hear information like Tom
Brady to the Cowboys like I laughed at
that
I went feels like Jerry Jones is trying
to create leverage with Dodd President
right Mike I mean I just went okay there
are gonna be host in this business
you're gonna run with this because it's
the Cowboys and Brady and that's a magic
elixir that's a Molotov cocktail but I
you know when you start to look at Brady
I don't we know the Patriots don't say
much and you know is Brady gonna be
leaking out something strategically here
I'm just trying to figure out now the
Titans we're in now the Titans aren't in
now it's the Raiders who might be you
know the the frontrunner feels like
we're gonna have all this talking is
going to go back to the Patriots well
here's the key two things first this
week at the Scouting Combine that's when
everything will be happening that we
won't know about where agents meet with
teams about impending free agents it's
tampering but everyone does it now and
you get an idea of who's gonna be
standing in line when free agency begins
so after this week that's when the ball
really swings back to the Patriots to
see if they can work out a deal with Tom
Brady he'll know what's behind door
number two generally the question is
what are the Patriots put behind door
number one and the deeper we get into
March without a deal for Tom Brady
that's when Patriots fans need to get
nervous and here's the real question
here's the second dynamic if he gets two
free agency and he's gonna do this Tom
Brady vanity tour where he has them come
to him that's the ultimate boss move
this isn't Reggie White or Peyton
Manning going city-to-city this is if
you want me you come to me I'm gonna sit
on my throne with my crown and you're
gonna have to come in and kiss the ring
and kiss my button and and you've got to
put you know you got to get my attention
who can wait with all these other
options out there in free agency which
teams can afford to play this out with
Tom Brady run the risk of not getting
him and then have a plan B you know what
the Raiders make the most sense Dan
because they can just hang on to their a
car hey we have a bird in the hand we'll
go try to get Tom Brady and if we don't
get him and all of the other guys we
were too pursued are signed elsewhere we
still got their a car we'll make it work
for one more year and then we'll see
where we are next year good to talk to
you Mike we appreciate your time all
right Dan see what
that's Mike Florio pro football talk for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]